the walls here look like they're moving
but it's just an optical illusion
created by video projections I've never
seen anything like it that's great sup
maliki I like it a lot it's really
diverse and impressive very good gun
destroyed yeah BTW guys me this is more
that it works with such simple visual
effect is a surprise the ova heusen
gasometer is the scene of this
illumination the 110 meter tall former
gas storage structure is hosting the
premiere of the 320 degrees light
installation the group behind the work
is called urban screen creative director
to Austin bajwa and his team had one
particular goal when they came up with
the design descanses I think the whole
thing is really more of a space
installation and immediate installation
we want people to walk in and look
around to experience the same thing from
their own perspective we didn't want to
cover it with pictures we wanted to
expand the space through video
projections of item video that was the
difficult part or rather the appeal of
the project and the artistic challenge
it took a year to get the installation
ready it's one of the biggest indoor
projection projects in the world just
setting it up took three months at the
end the group had 21 high performance
projectors beaming images around the
room covering an area of almost 20,000
square meters annotations I to SB
million for nine Suns we're talking
about 21 projection fields which all
have to fit perfectly with the building
and they have to be melded to create a
picture that means i don't see 21 fields
when i look up i see one big image
speed urban screen is a collective of
ten people among them architects
musicians and stage designers they use
light to transform public spaces like
the Sydney Opera House in 2012 or rice
university in Houston Texas also in 2012
ice and cattlemen from the core of the
idea is to take the projectors to an
urban space and change reality with
digital media reality and virtue ality
meet in a poetic way to shop advisor
bikini the installation at the gasometer
is part of an exhibition called des una
shine or the appearance of beauty it
features more than 170 copies of
paintings and sculptures from different
eras concentrating on the theme of
beauty p topic nikka is one of the
curators he specifically wanted to work
with urban screen disperse on door opens
clean the thing about urban screen is
that they use these new methods to
project across huge spaces and they do
it all manually they understand that you
can use simple forms to create great
inner movement in the viewer guns cause
another be vague omen in baccata olu ism
the installation has only just opened
and the group is already thinking about
its next project
within philippe de Madonna we love
modern architecture an example of an
object that would be really interesting
to project on is the Guggenheim Museum
in a or end of all patents on the other
hand we've also started to develop
objects ourselves that means we build
sculptures ourselves and then overlay
with media and then create a kind of
mixture of sculpture in media art eMCON
stashed in so of course we're really
keen on developing these sculptures
further nathangie the scope to an
invited to advocate it looks like the
lights aren't going out on urban screens
ideas anytime soon